more senators are coming out for and
against Gina
Haskell's nomination to be CIA director
a final vote is expected next week she's
under pressure because of her ties to
waterboarding and other extreme
interrogation techniques Senator John
McCain of Arizona said in a statement
that Haskell's quote role in overseeing
the use of torture by Americans is
disturbing Jeff Pegues he is on Capitol
Hill the scene of hospitals confirmation
hearing yesterday Jeff good morning good
morning Gina hospital has worked for the
CIA for more than 30 years but it was
the five years after September 11th get
most of the scrutiny here yesterday
Haspel was grilled about her role in the
CIA's enhanced interrogation of al-qaeda
detainees still she was able to secure
some important votes
she didn't toss up votes senators
Manchin and Collins are now supporting
has Bell's nomination she performed very
well others were not so in the final
decision the CIA veteran was peppered
with questions about her role in the
agency's enhanced interrogation program
after September 11th we got valuable
information from the briefing of
al-qaeda detainees and I don't I don't
think it's knowable whether
interrogation techniques played a role
in that during the 2016 campaign
President Trump was an advocate for it
- what sure works okay folks if this
president asked you to do something that
you find morally objectionable will you
carry that out my moral compass is
strong I would not allow the CIA to
undertake activity that I thought was
immoral even if it was technically legal
Democrats pressed a spell for more
details about her role overseeing a
so-called CIA black site where top-level
al-qaeda prisoners were subjected to
harsh interrogation techniques like
waterboarding she defended the agency's
actions the president has asserted that
torture works do you agree with that
statement I don't believe that torture
works I believe that in the CIA's
program and and I'm not attributing this
to enhanced interrogation techniques
that valuable information was obtained
from senior al-qaeda operatives that
allowed us to defend this country and
prevent another attack on twitter
president Trump praised has Bell's
appearance before the Senate Intel
committee but the pressure is still on
her because some senators are demanding
that the CIA released that memo that led
to the destruction of those 92
interrogation tapes
Norah alright Jeff thank you we've seen
now the senator Manchin senator Collins
have come out in support for her so it
looks like she may may pass the Senate
vote they were to who are up for grabs
all right there are centers